[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
[ __ ] them
right
i usually say happy hump day on a
wednesday
but it's not all happy not all sunshine
and rainbows today
i was hoping yesterday that i would come
on here and give you more commentary on
the hearing yesterday and we're gonna
get to that but
you probably understand how [ __ ]
absolutely pissed i am
about the footage
in the hallways of rob elementary
and not just the actual officers but
even the response from the city council
and yuvaldi and the in the mayor you
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] you goddamn
cowards
one person i'm truly pissed off and
whose fault this is
is greg abbott that's right he has blood
on his [ __ ] hands
there are a lot of republicans in this
country that should have no peace
anywhere brett kavanaugh can't go have a
[ __ ] stake
none of these [ __ ] republicans should
be able to go out in public
without us absolutely making them
miserable with the sounds of our voices
it's enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i'm [ __ ] pissed and maybe that's
the tony you want is [ __ ] pissed this
morning
i couldn't even hardly watch the [ __ ]
video
but you have to see it
i've watched it three or four times i
don't want to watch it
it's totally un-american
that's right it's un-american to to see
what happened in that [ __ ] video
to watch
to watch those law enforcement officers
run away and let children get [ __ ]
slaughtered
lock them the [ __ ] up that's what i say
[ __ ] them lock them up
enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
any uh the parents were begging begging
to go into the school
to stop the shooter from killing their
children
law enforcement officers with [ __ ]
body armor and guns
run away like [ __ ] little cowards
you think your kids are safe in this
country when republicans are in [ __ ]
control and the entire nation the entire
nation is [ __ ] losing their minds
this morning because 9.1 percent
inflation
as if the cost of bread going up or the
cost of gas going down
is going to [ __ ] put your children's
lives in danger
get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
you gaslighting [ __ ]
you gaslighting [ __ ]
trying to convince americans that
inflation is the number one issue that's
gonna harm you
you can't go to a [ __ ] parade you
can't go to a [ __ ] grocery store if
you're a black person you can't go you
can't send your [ __ ] kids to school
you can't go to church
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
goddamn [ __ ] i'm sick and tired of the
[ __ ] gaslighting and i'm sick and
tired of pro-democracy people buying
into the [ __ ]
that somehow inflation is the worst
thing that we can have
let me tell you what's worse than
inflation folks your children getting
murdered because republicans won't
protect them
greg abbott was cheering
cheering
that more people would have more guns in
texas so they can go into elementary
schools and pick apart [ __ ] little
children and teachers
he was excited about it he was really
even worried that california was selling
more guns in texas
it's
the [ __ ] gun [ __ ]
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
and realize what is at stake here
stop bitching about democrats asking for
[ __ ] money stop bitching about oh
well we didn't get this much debt
cancelled or that much debt our
democrats didn't didn't codify roe v
wade 30 years ago shut the [ __ ] up
the same [ __ ] the same
[ __ ] that sent that kid in that
school with that gun you want them in
charge of your courts you want them in
charge of your economy you want them in
charge of the inflation you want them in
charge of gas prices
that's who you want in charge
and you want this law enforcement these
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] punk ass law
enforcement cops that we got in this
country to [ __ ] enforce the laws that
republicans want to put in place that's
what you want
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we live in a goddamn democracy and it's
time we participate in the son of a
[ __ ]
participate fully
not just go mark your ballot
that's not what i'm talking about but
use the ballot the power of the ballot
make your voices heard
engage in politics politicize the
absolute [ __ ] out of this video
force your family to watch this video if
you have some dumb [ __ ] and your
family who's an ar-15 gun net p pew pew
pew
show him this [ __ ] video
show them there are no good guys with
guns it's not a it's a [ __ ] fallacy
it's all [ __ ] it's to convince you
that you owning guns is a great idea
because there's good guys and you're one
of them i mean until you turn into a
[ __ ] bad guy and decide to go into a
school and moder murder a bunch of
[ __ ] children why a bunch of goddamn
punk ass [ __ ] stand back and let you
do it
one of them
one of them eason even has the thought
while children are getting murdered
to sanitize his hands
now i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] you that is
real
he has such a disregard for those
children's lives as they're being
[ __ ] ripped apart
by an ar-15
that he decides well
might as well sanitize my hands
we've been wondering we've been
wondering
why
the ivaldi police
the governor
and all these agencies were covered what
they were covering up in the uvalde
shooting
what were they covering up
well now we know and greg abbott you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] liar you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] liar if there's not people
in texas right now right now
signing petitions to [ __ ] get rid of
that son of a [ __ ]
after the lies he spewed after these
children were [ __ ] slaughtered
knowing what he knew he he knew he
[ __ ] knew
and if he didn't know he didn't want to
know
which is even worse
inflation
inflation well
my god
inflation
did you see the gas prices went down
did you see inflation's up did you know
the opposite of inflation is recession
did you know that that high interest
rates are going to hurt
poor working people more than inflation
we're worried about that
that way they can sell guns so they can
slaughter our children so they can
slaughter you at a fourth of july parade
so they can come into your grocery store
and murder you on site
it's time it's time we do democracy
folks
it's time we do democracy here
it's time
not not [ __ ] last week
not
we we [ __ ]
we botched this in 2016 this whole
democracy thing and we botched it
several times before that and since
luckily we had enough goddamn common
sense to do the democracy thing in 2020
so i ask you i urge you
to join
every single pro-democracy coalition i
don't care if you [ __ ] agree with
them or do not i don't care if they have
the same [ __ ]
number amount of debt that you want or
if they're or if they're supporting joe
biden or if they're not supporting joe
bite pluck your head out of your [ __ ]
ass
these fascists are at the door
they're at the door and this is what
they want
this is what they want
you don't you don't
if the law enforcement agency and the
and the law enforcement officers that
were in the hallways of that school
while those children were being murdered
didn't want those children getting
murdered they would have went in that
room and they would have died to save
those children
those parents were begging to die to
save those children
they were doing more to keep the parents
out of the school to save their [ __ ]
children than they were doing to save
the children in the [ __ ] school
and now we know
now we have the evidence
we knew they were hiding something we
knew it
hell he was firing the gun outside the
school that's why they showed up within
three [ __ ] minutes of him walking in
the door
he'd already engaged and tried to shoot
people outside the school
a teacher made a 9-1-1 call before he
entered
door locks are not going to save your
children from these [ __ ] fascists
it's not and it's it is it's fascism i
don't care what you say you can oh well
tony it's second amendment blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah no it has
nothing to do with the second amendment
the second amendment has nothing to do
with an 18 year old kid going and buying
[ __ ] war weapons on credit not a god
damn thing does the second amendment
have anything to do with that not a
[ __ ] thing
never has never will you can't convince
me of it and i'm sure you can't convince
80 percent of america of it
it's absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous it
says right there in the goddamn document
well-regulated militia
while the railway the well-regulated
militia that we had that day were
cowards
they were cowards that's right the
well-regulated militia the law
enforcement agency that went in that
school to stop that gunman from
slaughtering children the well-regulated
militia
were a bunch of [ __ ] punk ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] those cops [ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ]
em [ __ ] em
and [ __ ] the city council and that
[ __ ] mayor [ __ ] him too
to act like the journalist releasing
this tape so the public knows what the
[ __ ] happened down there it that's
chicken [ __ ] you you [ __ ] i'm
gonna show you the [ __ ] tapes we're
gonna watch them here i don't give a
[ __ ] if they [ __ ] ban me i don't care
if they turn me off i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm showing them here
it doesn't show anyone dying in the clip
but it is not easy to watch folks but i
implore you to stay with me and watch
these [ __ ] videos and i implore you
to share these videos with your family
your friends that the [ __ ] pta
everyone in this country should watch
this [ __ ] video
and realize these fascists have been
selling and gaslighting us a bunch of
[ __ ] lies about how weapons and and
[ __ ] guns will protect us and it'll
make you safe bull [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all
[ __ ]
front back sideways all the way up and
down it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
there is no good guys with guns there it
doesn't exist it's [ __ ] it's a
fallacy
the guy that went into the school to
murder the children thought he was doing
the good guy thing
he thought he was the good guy
don't you get it
and they want you to live in fear
that's what this is about
that's why they want to strip away
bodily autonomy away from women they
want to give guns more rights than a
woman's body
and a woman's choice over her body
why would they want to do that why would
the why would the party of freedom in
liberty
my [ __ ] ass
would want to give guns more rights than
a woman
the choices over her body why why would
they want to do that
fear folks
fear
there's a handful of gun manufacturers
families that benefit from manufacturing
guns in this country
and ever since the late 90s in the early
2000s they figured out something that
fear
fascism
and school shootings and mass shootings
are good for business
it's good for business oh baby it's
profitable as [ __ ]
profitable as hell to put guns in the
hands of the actual well-regulated
militia that actually won't enter the
classroom to kill a gunman
it's profitable
just give all the teachers [ __ ] guns
that'll be profitable for us just have
guns everywhere really honestly
instead of fire extinguishers
because you're probably more likely to
be killed by a gun than a fire instead
of fire exchange let's just put [ __ ]
automatic rifles in the school behind
glass you know with a little hammer you
can break it get it out no
just in case the the well-regulated
militia won't actually come in and do
their job
and put their lives on the line to save
children from being ripped apart by an
ar-15
just just do that you don't need fire so
what the [ __ ] you need a fire
extinguisher for or an axe you don't
need that you don't need a water hose
you're not going to die from fire you're
much more likely to buy a die from gun
fire than actual fire
let's just do that
let's you know even a better idea for
the gun manufacturers and profits in
this country if that's what we're going
to talk about
because we're all oh the entire country
is focused on inflation and price is
going up
as if that's as if inflation is a bad
thing
i'm gonna explain to you why this
inflation thing is all a bunch of bogus
[ __ ] today by the way too
but why everyone's so focused on that
we might as well we might as well go for
the big profit and the big the big
inflation on gun prices before it gets
too bad and we might as well just give
the children many ar-15s they exist
the gun manufacturers are making them
why why why shouldn't we give them the
mini ar-15s to carry into school we're
giving them bulletproof backpacks
already
i mean god damn they already have
bulletproof backpacks why not arm them
you're gonna put these [ __ ] people in
charge of anything you're gonna put
these [ __ ] fascists in charge of a
state in front of your [ __ ] in charge
of your city
you're gonna put them in charge of your
state legislator you want to elect them
to the united states senate
so they continue the scourge of fear
so children can get slaughtered in
schools
so women have to [ __ ] have to have to
[ __ ] hide and duck across state lines
to receive medical procedures to save
their life or to have children that's
right a lot of women have [ __ ]
medical procedures so they can have
children in the future
it's abortion services
i don't know to extend life
pro-life party my [ __ ] ass
pro-life party my [ __ ] ass pro second
amendment my [ __ ] ass
if you were pro second amendment if you
truly are pro second amendment this
morning you should be [ __ ] furious
furious that the real the actual
well-regulated militia
didn't go in and kill the enemy
from slaughtering
ripping apart the bodies
of 19 small little children
you should be [ __ ] furious
and the cover-up
the cover-up should make you even more
infuriating
why didn't they just come out of the
school and admit it to the parents ah
he's got a he's got a high-powered rifle
in there it's really scary i mean you
don't want to go in there you be ripped
apart
i mean even us with our body armor we'll
be ripped to shreds we'll be dead in a
matter of minutes he's got a
high-powered rifle i mean [ __ ]
what do you want from us
i don't want to die that's what they
should have been telling the parents
outside that's what they should have
said
as they stop them parents from going in
and saving their children because they
wouldn't
jesus christ i'm going to show you the
video
and the attitude of the law enforcement
officers in that hallway for one of them
to walk over to the hand sanitizing
station and be more concerned about the
germs on his hands than the bullets
ripping through the bodies of the
children at the end of the hallway holy
[ __ ]
we have a disease in this country folks
we have a disease we talked about it on
the [ __ ] hearing coverage yesterday
about the secret service
about law enforcement about the
department of justice
you goddamn right we need reform and you
goddamn right we need to get we need to
get our [ __ ] heads on straight here
and stop letting the media [ __ ]
gaslight your dumbass and i'm not just
talking about the right wing media i'm
talking about the media in general they
they are derelict and their duty they're
not the enemy but they're [ __ ]
derelict in their duty at this point
both siding this [ __ ] both siding
everything lying to you gaslighting you
about [ __ ] gas prices and inflation
straight up [ __ ] gaslighting you
nowhere in the history of our economy
when we've had inflation and we have job
growth is inflation that [ __ ] bad
nowhere in our economy when we've had
inflation with inflating wages because
of job mobility because of demand have
we had that bad of an economy folks if
the economy was so goddamn bad it would
spiral into a recession on its own
you don't need to raise interest rates
to spiral a bad economy into a recession
it does it all on its own
but this morning they're going to raise
interest rates which is going to cost
you more money
it's going to cost you more money in
interest rates than the actual inflation
and the media is worried about gas
prices when gas prices are coming down
because the supply chain has a band-aid
on it
because
we have a [ __ ] artery
that is spewing or not spewing really
out of russia because of a war in
ukraine
and we are so focused so focused on 9.1
inflation that we don't see these
fascists knocking at our door
jesus christ yesterday we watched as liz
cheney in the january 6 select hearing
say out loud and yelled and screamed it
into a microphone that donald trump our
former president was witness tampering
to cover up his [ __ ] crimes that he
tried to overthrow our government and
our vote
so we can stop [ __ ] like in yuvali
happening that's right we can stop it
we can stop this nonsense
you can do it you just have to engage in
democracy
you cannot sit around
and not engage not talk
not find a candidate
find a candidate in your race or another
race
work hard for that united states senate
work hard for governor's races
donate money don't listen to these dump
bucks out there telling you that
democrats are asking for too much money
let me tell you something in the world
of citizens united
there's no way you're going to get any
policy you want without donating it's
not going to happen not going to happen
not going to happen you are not going in
this day and age
in this day and age and with citizens
united you're not going to overturn
citizens united without donating to get
the right people to get the [ __ ] job
done and if you really think that both
sides are the same you still have your
head up your ass
you still got it straight all the way to
the [ __ ] neck you got your head up
your ass
if you're like tony both sides are the
same democrats republicans it's the same
[ __ ] bull [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't watch
democrats for 30 years trying to
overturn the right to women have bodily
autonomy you didn't see that
you haven't watched as democrats
deregulated guns to make sure that a
[ __ ] 18 year old kid can walk into a
school and slaughter and rip apart 19
children and two teachers you did not
see that you are [ __ ] stupid you are
believing the gaslighting lies the same
[ __ ] lies they're selling you about
inflation in the economy the same [ __ ]
stop listening to the [ __ ] media they
are derelict in their duty
they're not the enemy they need to
change their ways they need to pluck
their head out of their [ __ ] asses
and do their [ __ ] job just like those
[ __ ] cops in that goddamn school
should have done their job they should
have laid their lives on the line to
save those [ __ ] children
i'm pissed this morning i'm [ __ ]
pissed and i'm gonna stay [ __ ] pissed
and you should stay [ __ ] pissed too
and if you need a little encouragement
come here every [ __ ] weekday i will
stay pissed for you i promise you i
promise you i will not stop until
fascism is underneath this [ __ ] rock
where it [ __ ] belongs
i won't stop i'm gonna do my part and
yell into this microphone every goddamn
day every [ __ ] one of them
no one will stop me
you have to engage in your democracy it
is time for us to believe in our
institutions it is time for us to
believe in ourselves it is time for us
the people we the people to take back
our democracy and stop letting them
[ __ ] confuse us
with inflation gas prices 9.1
the economy is not bad
the economy is not bad
let me let me tell you again the economy
is not bad
it's it's a difficult economy to work
through because it's a changing economy
got it it's changing that's why we have
the strife that we have
but you start believing their lies that
it's a bad economy guess what's going to
happen you're going to stop spending
money
do you know what's going to happen if if
everyone in this country stops spending
money
because because interest rates go up
because it cost you too [ __ ] much to
buy a car you it cost you too much to
buy a [ __ ] house it costs you too
much for those people out there that
rely on credit cards every once in a
while to make it from month to month
it's gonna cost you more than the
[ __ ] inflation
stop believing the [ __ ]
stop
what do you think interest rates are you
think interest rates are something that
rich people pay get the [ __ ] out of here
interest rates are the [ __ ] money
that rich people get
that's the money they're getting
so not only are they profiting off
[ __ ] gouging us
and particularly with gas prices and
some other [ __ ] things
if you want to go after inflation
there's your [ __ ] target gouging
corporate gouging
that's what you should start talking
about
oh pay attention to the [ __ ]
inflation number jesus christ have you
have you looked have you looked at wages
how they've inflated naturally the free
market has inflated wages and the reason
why is because there's demand baby
and people need your [ __ ] labor
and they'll pay almost anything to get
your [ __ ] labor
stop believing the [ __ ] stop
listening to the [ __ ] media
stop it they're derelict in their duty
and if you starve them off from
listening to them and you come and you
watch and listen to places like the tony
michael's podcast the midas touch
network you will actually
make them do their jobs
because they're on a profit mar
model too
engage in your democracy stop this
nonsense
this [ __ ] and uvalde that happened
where 19 children and two teachers had
to lose their lives
because greg abbott is in the pocket of
the nra
and the nra is a fascist organization
that wants to that wants to
rot fear on this country
and the more fear the higher the profits
for guns well [ __ ] that [ __ ] you take
your profits and stick them up your
[ __ ] ass
it's time
it's time
and trust me you you elect you elect
officials who are gonna have common
sense gun policy
actually thinking and sitting down and
doing the work of making gun safety and
gun policy in this country they're gonna
think hard and work hard for all other
sorts of policy not just [ __ ] work
hard at gaslighting you they'll work
hard at the policy that's the point
that's the difference between the two
[ __ ]
one party is not interested in policy
because interest in policy [ __ ] takes
money out of their pockets
it's up to you it's up to us we the
people
and if you want to stay pissed stay
right here
with d tony michael's podcast every
single weekday monday through friday i
promise you i will not disappoint you
i'm pissed
i'm just as pissed as you
and we will continue to be pissed
stick around we'll be right back after
these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
[Music]
sorry just get that [ __ ] off my chest
[Music]
i'm just sick
everyone else in this country
parents grandparents people who don't
even have kids who want to have kids one
day or have nieces or nephews want to
protect their children
want to protect it you know it's really
funny
that the save the children but save the
children save the children oh you can't
murder children
if you get rid of a clump of cells you
might kill the children if a guy with a
boner splooges on the floor oh that
might be that might be killing the
children
but when actually it comes to saving
children
like actually saving them
nope
nope nowhere to be found [ __ ] it man
why would you want why would you want to
save the actual children that are in a
school why would you want to do [ __ ]
like that why
why
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you can't gas like me
not gonna happen
okay well we got a lot of stuff to get
to today and i promise it's not gonna be
all pissed off stuff we got some we have
some uh
news out of the hearing yesterday now
big news that i want to talk about and
we we have a lot of video to get to but
i do want to show the uvaldi video i am
going to wait for my co-host to get here
for the yuvalny video
because i do want to show that video and
we're going to talk about the hearing
too
because there's there's more than just
just the video inside the school that i
want to show there's also the video uh
at the moment that the ivaldi shooting
happened where greg abbott came out in a
press conference and he [ __ ] lied he
[ __ ] lied to texans he lied to
america he knew he was lying
um that's the whole [ __ ] point that's
that's why we have to get rid of these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
we can't stand back and let these son of
a [ __ ] run rough shot over our
democracy
it's ours we can we can do it
but yesterday we we
we witnessed
a testimony
and deposition tapes
of people who are trying to run rough
shot over our democracy
and not only that
at the very end which was the the
the fire that liz cheney lit
under donald trump's ass at the very end
about witness dampering
i have the video here let's see if we
can um let's go to the
the tweety tweets here
uh you know what let's let's do this
let's do it official like i don't want
to do it unofficial
everyone likes the countdown for the
shitless roundup because that's what
we're going to do we got a lot of [ __ ]
to round up today a lot of video a lot
of tweets
some funny some funny [ __ ] there's some
funny [ __ ] in here don't don't get
discouraged today you will laugh you
will laugh at some of this stuff
today because i have some video that is
gonna
you're gonna go what in the [ __ ] is that
and there's a video that's
gonna make you laugh we have gabe
sanchez on the show and we have a video
that i want to that he found of sydney
pal on the internet so of course it's
gonna be funny of course it is so let's
start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back michael's
podcast you have reached the point of
the show where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
the [ __ ] list roundup
boy do we have some [ __ ] to round up for
you today holy moly let's start with
john bolton here um he's talking about
how he's
he kind of catches himself here he's on
cnn they're asking him about
someone
trying to commit a coup d'etat
listen to what jake tapper says he says
a dumb person can definitely try to
attempt a coup d'etat listen to john
bolton's response here donald trump
looking out for donald trump it's a once
in a lifetime occurrence i don't know
that i agree with you to be to be uh
fair with all due respect uh one doesn't
have to be
brilliant to attempt a coup one doesn't
have to be brilliant to attempt a cue i
mean it's not just like
we don't have to surmise that we watched
it like we watched really [ __ ] dumb
sons of [ __ ] try to commit a coup we
got evidence of it it's all over the
place i'm going to show you a bunch of
it today from yesterday's hearing
because there was a lot of bombshells in
yesterday's hearing
but some of the bombshells were just oh
yeah we already knew that this is just
the [ __ ] there's the proof
i mean one of them is that sydney powell
is absolutely off her [ __ ] rocker
she's off her [ __ ] rocker
so that's one of the things that we
already knew but we had evidence of
yesterday and we have more of it this
morning i guess she's out there posting
on social media about how [ __ ] crazy
she is
but listen to the stash here
john bolton listen to john bolton the
stash
tell us why you have to be brilliant
listen
uh i disagree with that as somebody who
has helped plan coup d'etat
what
what what what you helped plan what what
was that you helped plan the coup d'etat
like he's like well look here look
here's
jake tapper
i've been a part of planning cue date
ties my friend and i'm brilliant
like jake tapper didn't say you have to
be brilliant he just said you don't have
to be brilliant to try to attempt to
overthrow a government i mean you can be
a really stupid [ __ ]
and try to attempt to overthrow a
government you can be a really smart
[ __ ]
you can be a smart [ __ ] and try
to attempt a coup d'etat but it's not a
requirement to be brilliant to attempt
to overthrow a government you [ __ ]
idiot but let's listen
i watch he catches himself here
not here but you know yeah
yeah other players it takes a lot of
work and that's not what he did it was
just stumbling around from one idea to
another ultimately he did unleash the
rioters at the capitol as to that
there's no doubt
so he just assumes that trump is like a
bull in a china cabinet right this is a
guy who was excited who was excited to
be trump's national security advisor
who stayed there after he watched this
buffoon be a stumbling bumbling bull in
a china cabinet
what do you think he's always done he's
always stumbled around
what the [ __ ] are you talking about john
bolton you are such a piece of [ __ ]
trash this guy had the chance he had the
[ __ ] chance
to stop trump in his tracks and go
testify during the first impeachment
trial and he didn't because he wanted to
profit off a [ __ ] book this piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] him i don't
see this is the derelict of duty here oh
the [ __ ] media where jake tapper
placates to this son of a [ __ ]
jake capper should be grabbing him by
the tie and yelling in his [ __ ] face
should not give him peace we do not have
to give these [ __ ] traitors peace
because that's what john bolton is he is
a traitor to his oath because he held
the information that would have
impeached and removed the bumbling
stumbling buffoon who was trying to do
everything he could to overthrow the
government
what do you think a coup d'etat is you
dumb son of a [ __ ] let's bring in gabe
sanchez to see what he thinks of john
bolton i don't know me he might like
john do you like john do you think
john's i'm [ __ ] pissed this morning i
would say you know he really gives
bolton's a really bad name you know you
got michael bolton you know just jamming
out and then he got john bolton [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the bed here but i look at john
bolton and the thing is like he says the
quiet part out loud he goes oh this
wasn't a coup i've done other coupes in
other countries which is like which i'm
surprised like in this clip chapter's
like wait
you pulled a coup in other places when
under this administration let's back up
and talk about this for a sec because
that seems like a a big red flag here
you know i don't know well yeah well i i
mean maybe this is a whole what was that
uh uh episode i know i i yeah what what
was that what was that whoa whoa whoa
wait what was that speaking of what was
that there's a new episode of what was
that you can go to the mind as touch
youtube channel or you can go to the
what was that playlist here on our
channel don't forget to subscribe to the
tony michaels podcast here and you can
go to the playlist of what was that and
there's a new episode about the hearings
the update on the hearings and i think
gabe's going to try to put another one
together this week right
yeah this week i think you know uh the
the one that i just released yesterday
was a recap on just to catch you up on
days four through six
uh so so so not not the testimony
yesterday that no no no i need i need a
day to process everything i heard
i need to write the jokes for it so yeah
yeah but yeah there's there's day seven
which was yesterday and the final date
which will be next thursday i'm debating
if i should do just a separate one on
day seven by itself and then do a day
eight
um but i'm going to do
one on it's been in the back burner but
like with all the things we're working
on just haven't had time to do it so
there there is one that's going to be on
i think it might be a a a mix between uh
good guy bad guy but also with you valde
or might be uvaldi with a separate one
i'm not sure yet i'm trying i'm still
trying to figure out the timeline here
we're going to watch the good guy bad
guy stuff um
here we'll probably do it in the next
hour we're 42 minutes into the first
hour so we'll probably go to the ivaldi
stuff in the second hour i want to i
want to hash out a little bit of this
hearing stuff first yeah before i get
super pissed again because i'm going to
be super pissed when i have to watch
this video again
but yesterday's hearing was was uh
there was a lot of crazy [ __ ] a lot of
cr like just absolutely like what in the
[ __ ] like
crazy
the overstocked ceo so i i tweeted
this is hilarious so well let me let me
go to the original tweet here so i i
originally tweeted jesus the
overstock.com ceo enters the cue chat
for [ __ ] sake
and this tweet didn't even go viral no
it wasn't even big like they jumped
there was so much there was so much
stuff yesterday right but it was it was
one of the things that kind of stuck out
to me
because i think i think it was uh pat
sipoloni when he comes in
uh he's describing he comes in the room
and he sees these people sitting down
you know who the [ __ ] they are he's the
white house legal counsel right they're
having discussions about how to overturn
the constitution and the white house
legal counsel wants to be there when
that happens to tell the president
buffoon president
you can't do that you can't do that nope
that's not a thing that doesn't work no
that's not a thing either right like
like hershman hershman was again a star
yesterday him and his justice bat but
but pat cibolone describes walking into
the room and seeing the overstock guy i
think is what he referred to him at
first and he's like i didn't he's like i
didn't even know he was the overstocks
dot com ceo and like
you know you know at overstock they just
[ __ ] their [ __ ] drawers like a pr
team over there it's like oh my [ __ ]
god like they're a highlight right
because apparently this patrick byrne
whoever this [ __ ] weirdo is um
because he is a weirdo well i think
we've actually played clips of him here
before possibly yeah cause he's just a
cuban on her is all he is he's one of
these sydney pal linwood michael michael
well it makes sense right he's in the
he's in the room i mean when they broke
it down and they're like so they started
the meeting over here and then they went
to the yellow room in the private
residence like what what hold on
i need to know more about the [ __ ]
six hours or whatever that you guys were
talking but like how you went from there
to the private residency you're like
well
cocktails over a coup yeah sydney powell
ran out of dr pepper's in the in the
oval office so they had to go up to the
residence where there was more dr pepper
probably i have a i have an idea for a
dr pepper commercial okay good good good
yeah well maybe we'll play it on here
maybe they'll [ __ ] cease and desist
us that'd be great like i like to get a
season to see i don't know it's a parody
it's a goddamn period
seth it's not real okay so overstock
actually [ __ ] replies the official
account blue checked account replies to
my tweet here it says patrick byrne has
no affil association or affiliation with
overstock left the company in 2019 see a
market watch article here they're like
here here's the proof see see look make
sure you're not tweeting then he's the
overstocks
ceo and i actually went to the thread
and it felt like to me that the the pr
guy he just all he did was type in
like uh um overstock ceo yeah and then
he went down and anyone who didn't call
him a former you know right they just
they just [ __ ] they they spammed each
one and it was really you know it was
people who had bigger accounts that they
were spending verified accounts and
bigger accounts that they were spamming
uh the bad company even actually got one
as well a spam but i said here's what i
said and actually
maybe this spread it around for him that
patrick byrne is not not the ceo and he
was sitting there trying to [ __ ]
convince trump but the really the thing
here about this tweet that they're
really admitting is they let this crazy
kook be the ceo until 2019 right
like
you know it doesn't speak well when he
was the [ __ ] ceo until 2018 i think
it was some kind of [ __ ] scandal is
the reason why he had to leave
so if if the evidence wouldn't have come
out about the scandal he still might be
the ceo today yeah but i said i should
say
overthrow.com geez man
do what i said rebrand to overthrow.com
i guess so somebody's out scrubbing
socials is what i said i just thought it
was funny that overstock was so
concerned about yesterday's testimony
and it really shows you how effective
yesterday's testimony was that
overstock.com is like holy [ __ ] oh
you know why it's so such a big
controversy why he resigned 2019 does it
have to do with trump or something uh
well
i guess in a way it says in 2019 byrne
announced that he had a romantic
relationship with russian agent maria
bettina
and also made claims in support of deep
state conspiracy theory byrne also
claimed the fbi encouraged him to have a
sexual relationship with patina ensure
his fears that uh overstock could
could not control burns personality in
public comments ultimately led to his
departure
so he after it was revealed he then uh
he then resigned from his board seat and
position as ceo
on august 22 second uh 2018.
okay so it so he's a russian agent
was boning and listening yeah yeah i
mean it looks like somebody was like the
you know russians are trying to
penetrate their way into uh american
democracy yeah
something like that yeah
yeah geez these [ __ ] guys okay
so you actually the other the other
craziness because we made fun of cindy
powell um actually drinking dr pepper
which i'll show
uh some pictures of sydney powell in the
worst doctor commercial ever
she is a [ __ ] lunatic man like what
what floored me about
her deposition is she still she went in
and she did not plead the fifth like
michael flynn she did not mince where
she didn't actually try to adhere to
some sort of reality she just like hey
this this is my reality and i'm living
in it baby right she's like i'm sidney
powell and i'm going to drink this dr
pepper
and this is how i tried to overthrow the
government
oh that that's a great that's a great
she's got a bit of a deeper but she's
got that draw that goes on right right
which i do not do in this video but no
you you tweeted well no no you found
this video this is yeah yeah sorry i
found this video
in this video this is real this is
absolutely official official footage
official footage of sydney powell in her
office apparently yeah yeah
you say trump wanted to appoint sydney
powell's special counsel to investigate
claims of voter and electoral fraud
and this is what she discovered now the
crazy part about sydney powell
is that they were actually trying to
make her a special counsel to like
take voting machines and negate our vote
like that was the plan and yeah and eric
hershman and um uh
pat sipoloni were like what in the
actual who is she who the [ __ ] is she
yeah
but uh here here here's sidney powell in
this video that you found um and i think
it's very relevant i think everyone in
the world should see this video
especially anyone who would who would
like satire and parody or not like it if
you don't like satire and parody here's
your warning warning warning just turn
it off now
oh my god so let's let's let's go here
hello patriots it's me sydney powell
former attorney for president trump now
i don't know how much time i have left
before they find me but i figured it out
sami sosa of the chicago cubs corked the
ballots for the 2020 election now during
1998 in the major league baseball home
run record chase with mark maguire sami
sosa hit 66 home runs now in 1998 one
minus nine plus nine plus eight equals
nine upside down that's six you take
that six and you bring it with the 66
home runs and you get 666 or the mark of
the beast now sami sosa is also from the
dominican republic or known by the
locals dominion software
[Music]
i don't know where you found this but it
totally looks real it totally looks i
mean
let me tell you the connections that
sydney powell made
they seem pretty legitimate i gotta say
you know well you know what's funny
about it this video
is yes seth it is it is it's satire it
is parody and it's not real but here's
the thing
is that
what you said in this video is not far
off from what's i mean literally she was
saying like italian satellites and all
kinds of crazy nonsense all kinds of
crazy remember this is the same time it
was italian satellites it was uh it was
you go chop
hugo chavez 13 years he's been dead you
know whatever and it's like but he's
still alive he's running this thing and
then there was the bamboo ballots you
got the cyber ninjas like all of this
[ __ ] was hitting the fan at the same
time
these all these people were just
building each other up to be like i got
a crazy idea i don't have any proof but
i got a crazy idea and then someone else
was like ah you thought that was crazy
let me one-up you right now because this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] bananas and then it was
just like one and then one and then one
and then one and they all tried to
out-crazy themselves
and that is the reality we live in right
now that is the that is the timeline
that we're in where people were trying
to throw out these crazy [ __ ] ideas
of bamboo ballots and permanent markers
being the reason
like what the [ __ ] is going on they're
absolutely batshit crazy and then we've
got you know
sydney powell over here that is like one
leopard print shirt shy a [ __ ] tiger
king
you know [ __ ] the glasses and the shirt
dude it's the it's the gla it is the
glasses the shirt the gold uh necklace
she has on the fact that this camera is
[ __ ] terrible
like what did she record this on like
was it a chromebook was it like a
samsung galaxy 2 like what is she
recording this interview on that she was
like you know what this makes me look
even better you know and she's like it's
just insane
like what is going on
you'd think that someone was gonna claim
all these technological conspiracy
theories would have the decency to get a
[ __ ] phone that had h cute like just
high quality videos he's 720. she's not
even asking me
1080 here this is the year
2022. i'll give her the benefit it was
2021 when they did this interview and
here's the thing
she did not even do a good job of
getting good quality she was like ah
[ __ ] this committee it's like what the
[ __ ] is going on
oh my god let's watch a little bit of
this shitty video that they have this is
the actual uh evidence from the january
6 committee that they played yesterday
um this is their tweet this is from
their tweet and this is a pretty long
video so i don't know if we'll watch all
of it but we'll we'll go through some of
it here and then we'll get to the liz
cheney burning down
donald trump
did you believe that it was gonna work
that you're gonna be able to get to see
the president uh without an appointment
i had no idea
does she have an idea about anything no
i didn't know about that i mean i think
it's her play right she's like oh [ __ ]
because i mean this isn't the first time
that under oath like she had the court
case with the judge over zoom as well
and the judge was like
basically in so many words like you guys
are [ __ ] idiots
and then she was like well i don't know
i mean
maybe maybe i am maybe i'm not oh man
yeah
this is what i like when i do sedition
and try to throw a cool the best thing i
need at the end of the day is a ice cold
refreshing or rather she's like i need a
warm
lukewarm
temperature
[ __ ] diet dr pepper that's what i
need you know what i like to put my dye
dr pepper in the microwave and then
drink it
i like i like hot dr pepper like if if
anyone's seen the movie with uh
it's got uh
i think it's blast from the past
is with uh brendan fraser yeah right
yeah yeah well in that movie his dad
uh they're like the whole idea is that
they go in this bunker you know and
they're like oh shoot a plane crash but
they don't know that but on the top when
the cops and feds are investigating this
they're talking about who lived there
and one of the things is like oh yeah
well the person uh the dad in the
situation which was um
uh while i'm blanking on his name right
now uh christopher walken yeah
christopher walken he um
they're describing him and they're like
oh well the the
the neighbor said that the wife would
bring him out a pot of diet or of dr
pepper
and they're like what do you mean and
they're like yeah well she would boil
the dr pepper and bring it out to him
like that's the type of [ __ ] that sidney
powell was like exactly i do declare i
do need myself a diet dr pepper root
temperature boiling at best
oh my god let's let's continue this
nonsense and listen to sydney powell
just be really stupid because she also
told that federal judge that yeah no one
would believe the [ __ ] that i was saying
no yeah i mean she tried to take the
tucker carlson approach and and the
judge was like no no no no we can't do
that you you were very intentional right
claims you made right
uh in fact you didn't get to see the
president without an appointment we did
how much time did you have along with
the president i say alone you had other
people with you but right from his aides
before
the crowd came running
uh probably no more than 10 or 15
minutes so he said crowd came running
what what he means by that
is that this lunatic this dr pepper warm
warm dr pepper drinking lunatic
was in the oval office trying to
convince the former president united
states that he could overthrow the
government it would be okay no big deal
and his staff his white house staff the
legal counsel which is jordan generally
joined the president on i don't know
official white house presidential
business especially when they're trying
to i don't know commit a coup
would be in the room to talk him down
from i don't know breaking his oath
and what the legal ramifications would
be to break his oath that's the pete the
crowd who's coming running here so watch
was in that i bet that's the balloon he
said a new land speed record i got a
call
either from molly
very first
can you imagine what eric hershman said
in that phone call because he's like pat
cibolone's like uh because eric hershman
we know is a star in this and this in
these deposition tapes because he just
has no [ __ ] to give at all i mean this
guy doesn't want to go to prison for
[ __ ] trump hirschman it's clear he
doesn't pat cipolloni seems like he'll
he'll he'll you know play around with
going to prison for trump uh but eric
hershman's like [ __ ] this guy i'm not
going to prison for you eastman clark
any of you [ __ ] knuckleheads yeah
hershman just does not give a [ __ ]
but
i would love to hear the recording of
the call
from eric hirschman to pat zippoloni to
tell him to get down get your [ __ ]
ass down to the oval office right now
they are trying to [ __ ] commit i can
only imagine when eric gerschmann oh
yeah he's like are you [ __ ] serious
right now like eric hirschman you know
again these are people that stayed in
the administration throughout all of
this and it was up until the sixth when
they said okay we should probably give
this up right like everyone stayed did
not question did not say we shouldn't
really do this right uh eric hirschman
stayed along now obviously he's more of
the adult in the room where he's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] was flying everywhere and
these kids were you know like right i'm
trying to bat this [ __ ] right right he's
like you know the the
the um
the inmates were running the asylum
right like that's what he's more or less
talking about and again he stayed there
didn't really do anything about it
but
i can only imagine eric hirschman who
was like this is [ __ ] nuts you guys
are [ __ ] insane and this shit's about
to come back and [ __ ] bite you in the
ass right because they're not really
talking about january 6 here this is
december 18th right they're talking
about a meeting that happened at the
white house that mike flynn that [ __ ]
traitor who who was fired as the nsa
yeah because he was a [ __ ] traitor
he was
him and sydney powell come to the white
house with drunk ass rudy
to [ __ ] try to get to convince donald
trump to commit a coup
this isn't this is well before the
january 6 when this attempt fails
that's when they lean back on to january
6 because their attempt here is to seize
voting machines and just
extricate the vote just tell just
this vote didn't count this vote didn't
count this vote didn't count and they're
trying to use martial law and all kinds
of [ __ ] [ __ ] to justify this
delusional boneheaded scheme that has
no it's not steeped in constitutionality
at all but let's listen to what cassidy
hutchinson here and i think eric
hershman lets himself know in this video
too so that was the first point that i
had recognized
okay there was nobody in there from the
white house mark's
gone what's going on right now i opened
the door
and
i walked in
i saw general flynn
i saw sidney powell sitting here here's
the point where he talked i was not
happy to see the people
well again i i don't think they were
providing
well first of all
the overstock person
i don't know who the [ __ ] this guy was
why he was even there who in the [ __ ]
are you yeah he's like the overstock guy
i don't know who like look look guys i
don't know who he was who he is and what
the [ __ ] he was doing there but he just
showed up in the white house
can you imagine walking into the oval
office where uh someone like a mike
lindell is sitting there eating the
stuffing out of his pillow trying to
convince the president to overthrow the
constitution like the fact that we had
two
like retail consumer uh product company
q and owners or previous owners or
whatever that were in there whispering
in trump's ear you had mike lindell
trying to [ __ ] figure out how to do
martial law and you had
overstock.com guy over here that was
saying oh uh yeah we should we should
throw a coup because you know what's
better you know what's what's great for
business is uh is a coup it's edition
right right and we can sell we can sell
it anything that's that's over stock on
my website you know or on my previous
i looked at him and i website who are
you
and he told me i don't think i don't
think any of these people were providing
the president with good advice
and
so i i didn't understand how they had
gotten in
in the short period of time that you had
with the president did uh
he seem receptive to the presentation
that you were making
he was very interested in hearing
particularly here it is here's the worst
dr pepper commercial ever
she's holding it there and she takes a
big old swig to watch about the system
finding
and the terms of
13848 that apparently nobody else had
bothered to inform him of
boom
huge gulp
dr pepper warm dr pepper microwave dr
pepper what the [ __ ] they're like 23
flavors of sedition
dr pepper
dr pepper is totally going to send us a
season i hope they do no way oh just
wait i got something brewing over here i
i will proudly proudly
publish a cease and desist and we will
cease and desist but
um because i'm not against diet dr
pepper but i think it's hilarious i
think it's hilarious that that the
committee they could have stopped the
video here i mean look how they edited
this remember this is a production team
they are brilliant here and they're
editing because they totally they could
they could choose whichever angle they
want here they could go her or they
could go to uh they could go to people
asking questions well watch watch when
she takes the drink she's not saying
anything watch 3848 that apparently
nobody else had bothered to inform him
off i just love it how she's like we're
the bomb we're the boss she's like look
look i got oh yeah so
hold that thought real quick
bragging drink
bread
i mean i want to know like what did she
you know
after that moment where she chugs that i
would have loved if she [ __ ] just
crushed it was like
just crushes it on her forehead
she's like
another if i had the ability to make
that video i would make that video right
now of her i mean you know like some
sort of you know magic stick yeah yeah
yeah make it more make it crush it who
knows maybe i'll maybe i'll add that to
my commercial just [ __ ] crush it dude
oh my god he was very interested in
hearing drag drinking particularly about
the fifa funding
and the terms of one three eight four
eight that apparently nobody else had
bothered to inform him you could have
cut it right there right no and here i
can tell you this
from someone like myself
who has been cutting these recaps
together
i've on a couple times like when when uh
when jason miller was talking once i had
to cut it
because it seemed it was like oh [ __ ]
they're just like
he's not answering or he's answering the
question and you guys are looking at
yourselves or vice versa and i was like
this is terrible i was like i need to i
need to cut it
so that it won it's quicker or two it
looks like you know he was answering the
question the moment because then it just
looks like these people are watching and
you're just you're not sure
who's talking
and
uh they could have easily i can tell you
again from cutting these clips together
for the recaps they could have easily
cut to it the other side and had her
answer i mean you look at the you look
at mike flynn pleading a fifth you never
see him plead the fifth when she asks
when when liz cheney asks about a
peaceful transfer power it's back on her
looking over like this and he says plead
the fifth so they did it intentionally
right right this is all this is all
intentional to uh to to make this
production of what it actually is to
show
to show her actual disregard of what she
just said
by by doing by showing you know content
like ooh yeah we i i had the answers to
how to overturn the constitution i knew
how to overturn the constitution no one
else would tell him
yeah [ __ ] let's listen to hershman here
he's right after her
i was asking like you claiming the
democrats were working with yugoslav as
venezuelans and whomever else and at one
point
uh general flynn took out a
diagram that oh my god how much money
would you pay to see this diagram oh
yeah i don't know maybe maybe maybe
maybe
yeah well we'll show up online somewhere
i guess so what i want to make a note
here
not only does eric hershman have no
[ __ ] to give but he definitely had
[ __ ] to give about the quality of his
camera and the quality of his microphone
if no one's noticed you can actually
hear and see eric hershman here right
this is pretty good quality yeah once he
wants to he wants you to see that
justice bat in the background right it
doesn't he's like i want you to see
these are below i want you to look at
these metal hair scalp that i took off
when i was bashing [ __ ] brains in
with the justice bet
just too bad he wasn't doing it earlier
and had to wait until he was subpoenaed
way earlier like yeah and the first
impeachment he should have been right
brexit brings in with the justice bad
jesus i supposedly showed
i peter is all over the world
and
i speak who was communicating with whom
via the machines and some comment about
like nest thermostats being hooked up to
the internet
so it's been reported that during this
meeting ms powell talked about dominion
voting machines and made various can you
guess what uh michael flynn how he's
gonna answer here can you guess i'm just
i'm just wondering do you know what he
says because i know he's i i've watched
it but surely you could guess what he
says election fraud claims that involve
foreign countries such as venezuela
iran
and china is that accurate
the guy the guy walked around and he's
still walking around talking about this
stuff out in the open in front of
microphones yeah he's in front of
churches and he's got his whole like
cult give us money give me money i need
your money i need your money
but when he's in his deposition he has
to plea the fifth right
what the [ __ ]
craziness was the meeting tense
oh yeah uh
oh hell yeah it's not a casual meeting
oh hell yeah hell yeah no yeah of course
it was intense they were talking about
throwing they were overthrowing the
government well er eric hershman almost
it seems like to me when he's telling
the story here later on this video it
almost feels like to me he was going to
punch mike flynn
that's fine i would lay him out it's
great lay him the [ __ ] out at one point
he wanted to [ __ ] grab him and just
choke him it sounded like i mean like i
said in the in the last and this this
most recent what was that you know i say
you know jeffrey clark i was like if you
forget who he is don't worry he got a
very punchable face you know and and
mike flynn is very much the same way he
has a very punchable [ __ ] face
i mean at times there were people
shouting at each other
throwing insults at each other
um sounds like a really productive
meeting but yeah it sounds like [ __ ]
jerry springer on the couch like
chit-chatting do you recall whether he
raised to miss powell the fact that she
and the campaign had lost all of the 60
cases that they had brought in
litigation
yes he raised that and what was the
response
i don't remember
what she said i don't think it was a
good response
i don't remember what kind of [ __ ]
career she is against
i have no idea here's my name
i have a shitty camera and a dr peppa
let's watch simple onion hershman and
uh whoever the other guy was whoever the
other guy was she's talking about the c
ceo of overstock here because i don't
think she is is that what she started
well i don't know i mean who she said
cipollone hirschmann whoever the other
guy was maybe that was that was the guy
who said that when they asked uh if it
was uh oh the secretary yeah maybe yeah
that may be what it was when he was like
hey yeah hell yeah yeah it was a [ __ ]
crazy me just standing in the corner
he's like don't he's like don't mind me
and she's like okay i won't whatever i
just get me a dr pepper a warm dr pepper
make sure you heat that up
nothing but
contempt and disdain uh of the president
i remember the three of them were really
sort of forcefully
attacking
me
verbally um
he puts it he puts it like yeah they
were they were [ __ ] shouting
obscenities at me yeah they all right
right it's like they were attacking me
verbally
verbally it's [ __ ] ridiculous
eric
derek and we were pushing back and we
were asking one simple question
as a general matter
where is the evidence we've heard this
before in this hearings right if you go
back if you go back to the actual day
and i don't remember what day it is at
this point
where
the arizona house speaker
rusty bowers
sat on the in front of the public
and continued to describe how jenna
ellis and rudy giuliani kept pressuring
him to overturn the [ __ ] election in
arizona and he kept asking a question
i'm trying to remember what the question
was that he kept because they kept
talking about how dead people voted in
arizona and people who weren't
registered and they double voted and he
kept asking for something gabe what was
he asking for evidence oh that's what it
was yeah he was asking for evidence it's
weird it's something that this uh this
republican administration this this
trump administration uh never
never ends up having you know it doesn't
happen and it's not just administration
it's anyone who follows trump you make
you hear claims of like oh these many
people were you know like so many people
died during the blm protest show me
proof it's all over cnn
is it i can't find it anywhere i can't
find anywhere there were there was so
much voter fraud and all these dead
people were voting that's crazy because
my grandparents not vote this election
they're both dead so i don't know what's
going on right
well that's the thing though is that
that is th that is the at the heart of
the matter here is it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] lies right all of it it's all
[ __ ] lies and the only reason why is
because
the truth would have been that he
conceded a week after the election when
joe biden was the president-elect that
would have been the truth and really if
he would have done that he wouldn't be
in so much goddamn trouble today because
he's in way more trouble i believe he's
in way more trouble now
uh with the witness dampering than he is
yeah january oh man now yeah you talk
about you talk about a federal crime
that the feds take seriously especially
when you're not president he's not the
president he didn't he did not he's not
the president of the united states and
he's tampering with witnesses this is
real a really [ __ ] serious thing and
we'll get to that but let's listen to
what else
pat patsy bologna has here to say
so what response did you get when you
asked his pal and her colleagues
a variety of responses based on my
current recollection included he means
[ __ ] that's what he means there that
that variety of rece a [ __ ] it was
just pure utter [ __ ] is what he
meant to say
you know
i can't believe you would say something
like you know things like this like what
do you mean where's the evidence you
should know yeah
things like that or it's all over cnn i
disregard i would say a general
disregard for the importance of actually
backing up what they say
and you know then there was discussion
of well you know we don't have it now
but we will have it or whatever
i mean i i i've heard that too
i heard that too in the [ __ ] hearing
with rusty bowers girody
rudy giuliani
grandpa farty mcsharty rudy giuliani
drunk rudy rudy kaludi and jenna ellis
kept telling
the speak the arizona house speaker that
yeah well uh we'll get it yeah in a
couple weeks couple weeks yeah i have
that every time they're on the phone
this is what i mean in the in in the uh
testimony that brexit bowers gave every
time they would speak on the phone or
every time they're in person or whatever
it might be you know they're like yeah
yeah yeah
get him that stuff get him that stuff
rudy and rudy says yeah okay sounds good
i'll get i'll get em that stuff right
and then you know with jenna ellis same
thing you're like well did you bring it
and jen is like
no well no i didn't i didn't bring it
because i didn't bring it down exist
we can't bring something right it
doesn't exist and rusty bow is just like
then why are we meeting like what the
[ __ ] is the point you were supposed to
become prepared with the material out to
arizona they went to arizona right
and that was the moment when they're
like well we have lots of theories but
no evidence and that's the moment when
rusty bowers and the rest of that crew
were like oh god damn it
these people don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about right it's like
him and and his counsel were like
oh
okay and we should probably back out of
this one as soon as possible you're
gonna go to a federal prison right
try to overturn a [ __ ] election a
federal election let's listen to uh dr
pepper spokeswoman
here at sydney powell and if if it had
been me sitting in his chair i would
have fired all of them that night and
had him escorted out of the building but
just ever kind of both challenged what
she was saying
and
she says well the judges are corrupt and
i was like everyone
every single case that you've done in
the country you guys lost every one of
them is corrupt even the ones we
appointed
yeah
and
i'm being nice that was much more harsh
to her
because it's [ __ ] it's absolute
[ __ ] like to hear someone
and this is the same [ __ ] that we've all
heard before like i've done videos where
was like bill barr said there was no
widespread voter fraud and like yeah
well a judge is like all the [ __ ]
judges said no especially the ones that
trump put in office so if there's any
giuliani even rudy giuliani in front of
those judges said no there was no fraud
because he couldn't say that there was
because he had no proof and it would be
fraught he might be defrauding the court
exactly
and it's
just like elon musk filing papers to say
he's gonna buy this [ __ ] thing like
until the [ __ ] money is processed
until the evidence is in front of the
judge [ __ ] ain't real man
so you know it's just a one another one
of those things where you know rudy
giuliani and everyone else want they
both they want to believe it whether
they actually believe it or not they
want to believe it right so much that
they filed [ __ ] court documents to
say that they were
uh they were experiencing widespread
voter fraud and all these people all
these testimonies and they're like we
have all these [ __ ] affidavits and
it's like they don't mean [ __ ] right
they could be anyone from anything you
could make it up you could say that john
doe down the street on on sixth avenue
said that he saw someone go in and drop
a ballot in the box and he knew that it
was actually for trump but somebody in
the box switched it around and made it
for biden like there's [ __ ] little
trolls in the box i guarantee someone's
gonna make that make that kind of well
he's like trolls i also made it boxes i
also made a video about that type of
thing when they were doing illegal
ballot boxes in california in southern
california but it's just it's just
insane i mean it's they're they're
uh
debunked conspiracies theories that are
bad [ __ ] crazy and they wanted to come
up with any excuse to make this a
reality so they could stay in power
again it was they were having a [ __ ]
rager and they didn't want it to end and
the cops showed up and then they're
trying to figure out a way to to block
them off from not coming in
right well it was a hell of a rager it
sounds like let's keep jesus so one of
the other things that's been reported
that was said during this meeting was
that president trump told white house
lawyers mr hirschman and mr sipoloni
that they weren't offering him any
solutions but miss powell and others
were so why not try uh what ms powell
and others were proposing do you
remember anything along those lines
being said by president trump
they do that sounds right
i think that it got to the point where
the screaming was
there's no [ __ ] hershman completely
completely
out there i mean i'm telling you it was
late at night
it's a [ __ ] episode of uh of
jerry springer you know
it is listen i think hershman i think
this is where he describes uh almost
coming to blows been a long day and
what they were proposing
i thought was nuts
i'm gonna i'm gonna categorically
describe it as
uh here's here's the best the best
footage ever when you have uh
almost in the gr one foot in the grave
giuliani here describe the meeting it's
every time i see these videos i mean i
joked about with you and other people
yesterday i was like this guy looks like
he is on the brink like at any point
he's gonna [ __ ] die on camera in
these [ __ ] hearing depositions
right well he looks i i don't know if
that's his lawyer his mortician that is
waiting i don't know he's probably it
could be his doctor he's like okay keep
it calm you know we we talked about this
your heart rate gets real high and you
got to keep it chill right right
you guys are not tough enough
maybe i put it another way you're a
bunch of [ __ ]
excuse the expression but that that's i
i'm almost certain the word was used
flynn screamed at me that i was a
quitter and everything kept on standing
up and turning around and screaming at
me
and then at a certain point i had it
with him
this is this is where he describes it
this is it
and and when he started this when he
started this description i'm thinking oh
my god is he gonna say he [ __ ] laid
him out
i was so excited in the moment i was
like did he have the justice bat in his
[ __ ] hand i know why why like i
we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life what would
make you not believe that eric hershman
carried in the justice bat in a [ __ ]
folding chair right into this meeting
in this cage match to [ __ ] fight
fight mike flynn and sydney powell i
know he's like he's like holding up the
[ __ ] lincoln bust he's about to bash
his head and he's like no you [ __ ] you
know i'm telling you let's listen to
what he says
so i yelled back
either come over
or sit your ref and ass back down the
president and the white house team
went upstairs
to the residence
but to the um this is where he's dying
yeah
public part of the residency does he
have the big market
where you can have meetings in the
conference room
they call that the yellow oval
yes exactly the yellow overalls
the yellow oval yeah yeah yeah he
remembers now oh he's called to the
upper
um upper decker
and i'm not exactly sure where the
sydney group went i think maybe the
roosevelt room
and i stayed in the cabinet room which
is kind of cool i really like that
all by myself
at the end of the day yeah
for yourself you're [ __ ] your ass off
no one wants to be around you [ __ ]
flatulence everywhere you go
this is crazy that they're they're
surmising to commit a coup here with
martial law and taking dominion machines
and all kinds of crazy ass wacky [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's even wackier than go down to
the capitol and just murder a bunch of
people and we'll declare
trump dictator like that's a little
that's more of a straight line to i'm
not going to be president to i want to
be dictator right like usually a violent
coup is more of a of an obvious coup
this one was like i don't know just
drive around in your pickup and start
season voting machines
like mike flynn's gonna get in his
pickup and just start going and getting
voting machines this is [ __ ] crazy
ass bonkers delusional q and on type
[ __ ]
we landed where we started the meeting
at least from a
structural standpoint which was
sydney powell
was fighting
mike flynn was fighting they were
looking for avenues
that would
enable
that would result in
president trump remaining
president trump
so in other words in other words
he wanted to remain in power they didn't
want a peaceful transition
it's the main crux of this meeting on
december 18th now
this was really the focus of this part
of the hearing where they're trying to
describe to the country they're trying
to tell you the people out there that
january 6
is just was just the last ditch effort
that was the last ditch effort
to try to make trump the dictator there
were several attempts before that this
meeting being one of them where they're
trying to convince the president united
states to sign an executive order which
it was drafted
the executive order was drafted for him
to to go out and for the attorney
general to seize all the voting machines
so he can negate your vote like that was
the attempt here of the coup i mean it's
absolutely batshit crazy but that's what
they wanted to do
now
rather you know
donald trump believes it or not because
he was freaking out yesterday absolutely
freaking out but this one because this
is going to lead me into because i he he
he post on true social and we
we very rarely post his post i mean his
real ones his real posts yeah all right
but uh but but he posts this on true
social it says democrats now want lost
wisconsin the cheating and
irregularities were unbelievable blah
blah big lie i won
let's steal the election twenty
according to who the democrats now lost
was gone like what is he talking about i
was so there was a supreme court
decision in wisconsin where they
a fascist deemed that the ballot drop
boxes were unconstitutional in wisconsin
now this is not a retroactive decision
because laws don't work retroactively
that's not how it works also even if
that happened it would not change the
outcome of the election right exactly
right but here he's trying to grant he's
still doing the [ __ ] that they were
doing in that room
on december 18th he's still doing that
[ __ ] he's still continuing to try this
coup
here's what i said
i said didn't you hear him hear my man
you're going to prison for witness
tampering among other crimes because
this is just hilarious
this is hilarious that this delusional
fool
is on his phone posting on what is his
fraudulent social media site yeah saying
that he's he's still doing the [ __ ] that
they described like literally he is
doing the [ __ ] they're describing in the
hearing he's and he's not like quietly
doing it yeah he's doing it right out in
the open right here you know he's just
he's just speaking the truth speaking
the truth that's what he's doing
too central over there jesus christ but
here is the uh here's the video
uh
and i believe that yeah this is this is
the very end
of the hearing
this is from our coverage at the minus
dutch network
from our cameras there
in the room this is liz cheney at the
very end absolutely burning down donald
trump's house watch this video you gotta
listen to this and one more item
after our last hearing
president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer to the
call
their lawyer alerted us
and this committee has supplied that
information to the department of justice
let me say one more time
we will take any effort to influence
witness testimony very seriously
thank you mr chairman i yield back
do not [ __ ] around or you will find out
is what liz jane is saying now here's
the thing about this this last clip and
i and i i'm gonna play it again because
i think this is one of the most
important pieces of sound that came from
yesterday and the reason why it's
important because this if this doesn't
quell this nonsense that the select
committee isn't trying isn't trying to
make sure that the department of justice
knows [ __ ] that the department of
justice isn't working hard to [ __ ] if
there is indictments that can be brought
against these [ __ ] that they're
gonna bring these indictments this
should shut that [ __ ] up just like the
[ __ ] inflation talk which i i don't
know if we'll have time today because i
want to get to this ubaldi this ivaldi
video yeah but this should shut that
nonsense the [ __ ] up
here's the thing
liz cheney is is telling the public
that donald trump in the last week not
january 6 not december 18th in the last
week donald trump has committed a
federal crime that carries a huge
sentence if you are indicted and
convicted on
tampering with a [ __ ] witness
in a federal investigation that is a
serious [ __ ] crime and it carries a
very big sentence
let's listen to it again because she
says
after our last hearing that is super
important let's listen and one more item
after our last hearing president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer to the
call
their lawyer alerted us
and this committee has supplied that
information to the department of justice
so if anyone's out there still bitching
oh the select committee isn't making
refer criminal referrals
there you go
there you go
yeah this is uh
well the thing is newsmax is now
claiming that it was all a butt dial
they're like
they're like oh oh he didn't mean to do
that he pulled a rudy here's here's the
thing is newsmax doesn't know who he
called that's what liz cheney did here
and that it that is really the heart of
it is she basically looked at trump and
said we know you called this person
we're wondering who else you've called
right is basically and without because
she doesn't want to say the person
because maybe she even has evidence that
someone else has been called
that had been called maybe that's why
they were protecting some of these
people like cassidy hutchinson and the
witnesses from yesterday i think the
other thing too is you know she's
stirring the pot they're doing a very
good job of getting people inside the
circle to be like whoa whoa okay this is
serious [ __ ] man she's put like it's not
just
rumors or it's whispers or something
it's like now we're gonna put it on
blast here's a graphic of two instances
where cassidy hutchinson was attempted
to have witness tampering done against
her right like we have someone who is
actively trying to do this we find out
that somebody through some association
that mark meadows reached out to cassidy
hutchinson and said you know be be loyal
if you do this right we'll look out for
you you know it's very kind of mob mafia
like mob family kind of talk and this is
another example
but what i find interesting and i think
maybe is also the kind of the reason
here is is liz cheney
is yeah she's putting out there to be
like look we know you've been trying to
contact people and this is only one of
the people that we're revealing we might
come forward in the next one where we
discuss the 187 minutes or whatever it
is to then say oh we also know about him
and her and him and her and this person
that person
but also
i think there's something of a
maybe a play here well trump will just
[ __ ] admit it himself or he'll be
like i didn't call this person and then
they'll be like we never mentioned their
name
well here's like why would you say that
you know here's some more
snippets from this earring that i want
to get out there real quick cause i i
gotta show this video uh of someone
slamming josh hawley and i also want to
play you the the tape of steve bannon
but here is gabe's tweet about sydney
powell city about looks like a villain
from true detective
yeah 100 percent so let's i got i got to
move quick here we gotta we got tick
tock here so uh the next thing i want to
show you is uh brett mizella's this is
hilarious um you see this uh photo here
of stephen miller it says pretty wild
they got stephen miller in his natural
habitat i can't we gotta laugh because
we're gonna get really serious about
this juvaldi stuff here so we gotta
laugh a little bit um
it's it is great here's the dr pepper
worst dr pepper commercial ever there's
the um
from jordy thank you jordan
this edition everyone was like
um but i want to get to this uh steve
bannon tape have you listened to this
tape no but actually i've been getting
people messaging me to say that i should
do what was that on this tape
on the steve bannon one it's possible
actually a lot of people have been
saying you need to make that like a 30
minute show or something which i don't
think people know how much how much time
going to that few minutes a lot a lot of
work that goes into it so i appreciate
everyone who watches and likes it maybe
maybe when we get our production staff
bigger we'll we'll work on making that a
30 minute show but here is here is a
here's a meeting that was recorded from
steve bennett now remember
this is before the election
this is before the actual election let's
listen and what trump's going to do is
just declare victory right he's going to
declare a victory
but that doesn't mean he's the winner
he's just going to say someone yeah yeah
we know
[Music]
yeah the democrats
more of our people vote
early that count theirs voted mail and
so they're gonna have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of that's our strategy he's
going to clear himself winner so when
you wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm they
already knew this they knew what they
were doing they were planning it this
was the whole plan the whole time they
knew he was going to lose
this is them and minnie and this is
october 31st yeah remember so this is
right before the election this isn't
like two years before the election
this is them planning steve bannon
planning and he's in the ear of the
president obviously
because this is exactly what he did but
listen to this oh my god it gets [ __ ]
worse
i'm gonna have a t for crazy the media
crazy the courts are crazy and trump's
gonna be sitting there mocking tweeting
[ __ ] out you lose
i'm the winner i'm the king
and he'll be all over he'll be he'll be
going where's hunters hunter on a crack
pipe i mean no he'll be because then it
doesn't matter remember
here's the thing after then trump never
has to go to a voter again
what
i'm sorry what was that
so in other words what he's saying here
because i think he's talking about two
terms of presidency but it is really
dark and it gets really dark here
because he's talking about trump never
having to get another vote again listen
yeah he's going to fire ray the fbi
director before the scene and say [ __ ]
you how about that because he's never
going to he's he's done his last
election oh he's going to be off to
chase
if trump is if trump is losing
by 10 or 11 o'clock at night
it's going to be even crazier here's
where it gets through
no because he's going to sit right there
and said they stole it i'm not going to
agree i'm directing the attorney general
to shut down all ballot places in all 50
states it's going to be enough he's not
going out easy if biden's winning
trump is going to do some crazy [ __ ]
now in the beginning when he's joking
the people are like clapping and
laughing but when he gets to that part
when he really is talking about trump is
just going to overthrow the constitution
the united states he's not going to he's
not going to abide by the democracy
selecting joe biden he's just going to
declare himself king because he'll never
have to get another vote again it gets
really [ __ ] dark like you can hear
the mood of the people in the room yeah
change it's [ __ ] weird now that this
was put out by
motherjones.com and you can go and go uh
look at that report but that's some
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] and then again they
were they were planning this
for a long time a long time they were
planning this that they knew he was
going to lose
so let's do this let me i think was
there one more thing i wanted no i let's
do this because i want to get to this
uvaldi tape listen audience um we're
going to play some tape
some cam footage
um that is in this inside and outside
the school
of rob elementary in uvalde texas where
the shooters slaughtered 19 children and
two teachers
it does not show
anyone getting shot but it is very hard
to watch i've watched it several times
this morning it's gut-wrenching
i watched it several times so i knew
exactly what i was looking at
because i want to be accurate here i
think everyone in this country needs to
watch this whether you have children
grandchildren
rather you are a certain age i think all
18 year olds should watch this
and
we should watch this we should not look
away we cannot look away and we cannot
stop holding these fascists accountable
because that's what caused this
it wasn't that the 18 year old
was demented that caused this
it was the the fascist giving him the
ability to go into a gun store pick up a
couple guns on credit and and as much
ammo as he needed to murder dozens of
people and then just simply
walking into a school and ripping in the
shreds with a weapon of war and and the
republicans republicans and the nra in
this country and the and the few
families that own gun manufacturers
did this it is their blood on their
hands so let's do this let's go to a
break we'll come back
and we'll get to uh the
the very hard to watch
evaldi cam footage don't go away we'll
be right back right after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
we are
40
minutes
[Music]
inside the rob elementary in uvalde
texas where
um
the republicans in texas and all around
the country
not only allowed but encourage
this person to do what he did
and while it happened because we know
they've been covering something up the
law enforcement agencies around uvalde
i've been trying to cover something up
not just the law enforcement agencies
also the governments
the city government the the governor of
texas i'm gonna show you a video where
he just outright lied to the american
people and the people of ivaldi and the
people of texas and he should be held
accountable for that uh 100 should be
accountable he if he knew this stuff and
it surely is provable whether he knew
this [ __ ] or not and he was briefed on
this [ __ ] what you're going to see in
this video um that [ __ ] lied and
he did it intentionally and
he he needs to be held accountable and
the way that you can hold him
accountable in texas
is to vote against that son of a [ __ ]
vote against him and vote against all
republicans in texas because they did
this to these children
in uvalde by allowing allowing these
weapons of war
to be put on the streets and even even
law enforcement is terrified of them the
quote-unquote good guys which is a
fallacy
we're going to watch it here
again
this even gives you the warning here
the following video and audio is
disturbing viewer discretion is advised
even at one point in the video the
editor makes a note that they took out
the
the audio of the children screaming
um
so that this video would be even
watchable is i i'm thinking that's why
they took it out don't you gabe is
it had nothing to do with um the audio
being skewed because the audio is kind
of it's really bad on this camera yeah
because this is like a um just a is it
so it's horrible audio but they took out
the screaming of the children so it's at
least watchable but i believe everyone
in this country should watch this video
and we're going to watch it so
again i do i urge my audience do not
look away you have to know these things
and really honestly you should be
putting this in front of the faces of
everyone you know to make them watch
this
make them watch what republicans have
done did to those children in uvalde
that's what that's what happened here
the blood is on their hands
and it is the [ __ ] guns and
republicans want everyone to have guns
so that everyone lives in fear in this
country that's their goal so let's watch
this footage it starts outside the
school
when he drives the car into the ditch
yeah
now for everyone who's listening it says
on may 24 surveillance videos
shows a truck crash near rob elementary
i actually i don't i still don't think
he crashed i think he drove it into the
ditch but but maybe it's just me because
it does but anyways
now here you see uh the circle and it's
putting out two two men
now these are the men that we now know
worked at like a funeral home that was
nearby right they heard the truck go
into the ditch so they tried to go see
if something was wrong
now the the caption on the video here
says the gunman in the crash vehicle
fires three shots at the two men who
approached approach the crashing
so he did not wait to go into the the
school to fire this weapon yeah he is
outside the school he's just gotten out
of his truck
these two men are approaching to make
sure he's okay
and he fires the weapon at them
you can watch here as the men run away
terrified for their lives because they
realize this guy's got a weapon a war
and they definitely are no match for it
right
here they here they won the one guy
falls down here he's running so fast
and they run across the parking lot to
get away
now this call here is before he enters
the school you're going to hear a call
here
this is a teacher calling 9-1-1
to report the gunman this is before he
enters the school so 9-1-1 and the
authorities knew before this
this this piece of [ __ ] entered this
school with the weapon
to slaughter these children this
teacher's calling 9-1-1
the kids are ready
she says the kids are running
um he's outside the school now listen to
what she said because he actually fires
the weapon again outside the school
the caption says the gunman begins
shooting at the school from the parking
lot so he's
he's unloading rounds
at the building
before he enters the school and this is
why this is the [ __ ] that they've been
covering up gabe because the timeline
was always [ __ ] that they put out it
was always [ __ ] they kept i mean
even even a week after the
the shooting happened
you know they they had changed the story
i think it did i mean and this was the
first by the way this is the first what
was that that i did i covered this
and
made reference to that and the first
point that i had which was they had
changed their story so many times you
know and i jokingly said i was like
we're going to find out they probably
escorted the guy into the building
but at that point they had changed their
story 12 different times and now what
the timeline was he was here he was
there he was he was approached he wasn't
approached the door was open the door
wasn't open it was how long was he in
the building how long were the cops in
the building were they in the building
were they not in the building right
because they went in and they helped
their kids but they didn't help the
other kids like
every time every time he does come out
it's worse and worse and we had video of
the parents trying to get into the
school that's part of the video that the
public did see because that's the video
they got released outside the school but
this is the first time the public is
seeing this footage um so here
here he is firing and this is 11 32 is
the real time on this video the time
stamp
where he's firing
outside the school at the school
[Music]
now here is uh is a clip from
you see on the right hand side we have a
a different video
and this is a footage from someone's
cell phone
um it appears and then and there's
filming the gunman entering the school
and then this camera here at 11 32 57
um the bystander video captures the
gunman entering the school so this is
the moment when he enters the school at
11 30 almost 11 33.
so here we see at 11 33 almost on the
dot he's standing outside the door
looking in
and i don't know if he's
you know maybe he's worried that there
might be a an armed officer in there i
don't know or maybe he's wondering if
there's children right inside the school
so he can you know i don't know what his
thoughts are but
he obviously is peering into the school
and it doesn't take him long to realize
he can walk right on it
so this is 11 33 you see the gunman here
now this is this is getting very dark
and it's about to get darker
but you see that this is kind of an
intersection here of two hallways and
it's at the end of a hallway and there's
classrooms here that he walks past now
this actual um this this kid because
he's what he is as a kid
he went to this elementary school so
he's at least familiar a little bit with
the school now
it does kind of bring up like why he
chose that one room
right you know it
maybe there is significance to it
because there's clearly three classrooms
here and i'm not sure which teacher was
on the phone but he obviously was firing
outside the school right before he
walked in this door because it's just a
within a minute
right right so it it appears that one of
these teachers maybe even one of these
classrooms was looking out the window um
and and maybe even that's where she
peeked her head out
um so you watch the gunman walk into the
room into the hallway now he he stops to
pier
right he stops to peer around i don't
know if he's looking for people as
targets or he's looking if he's making
sure he's not a target here it's very
unclear but he's trying to make sure
that this hallway is clear of something
and that's when he actually proceeds to
walk down the hallway through this other
doorway that you're going to see in the
fisheye camp
so here he proceeds and he's just
nonchalant you know just carrying his
gun with one hand yeah you know um pan
through the hair he's gonna go do his
thing
no you know that the governor of texas
has allowed him to buy this gun on greta
he's gonna go have fun with it [ __ ]
um so here you here you see though that
this hallway continues down this is like
a t intersection here now watch as a
young kid
uh comes down the other hallway from the
other direction and he tries to turn
this corner and he notices
this kid with a gun and a body armor and
he stops in his tracks like a deer watch
here he is the youngest comes around the
corner
and he stops like a deer in headlights
yeah
as he watches the gunman down the
hallway
now this kid um
stands there and kind of watches him
this is where it gets
very hard to watch because you're going
to start to hear gunfire here
um
and again
we cannot look away at this
we have to as america realize that this
is what these republicans are are are
pushing this fear and these guns and
that we have to have these things
to protect ourselves and it's not
protecting us it is [ __ ] killing us
so you're going to hear the gunfire
again the the editor of the film took
the
it's even hard to even say it the
screams of the children
out of the video here
listen
you see the young man who was around the
corner that stopped like a deer he
realizes
now his worst fear
so he runs for his life and again you
can see the editor's note up here on the
video it says editor's note the sound of
children screaming
has been removed
the gunman fires the ar-15 inside the
two classrooms for two and a half
minutes
so the gunfire goes on for a long long
time
and then we watch as law enforcement
enters the building
100 rounds
now look at the time stamp here it's
11 35 59
so it's three minutes
three minutes after heath walked through
those doors now for two and a half
minutes he unloaded 100 rounds and the
reason why it only took them a hundred
um two and a half minutes to unload 100
rounds is because of republicans
okay this is because of republicans is
the reason why this guy was able to go
buy a [ __ ] gun on credit this is greg
abbott's fault
he signed the [ __ ] bill and he was
proud of it
this this
piece of [ __ ] was able to rip through
these little bodies with a hundred
rounds of ammunition
because greg abbott wanted him to
yep
i don't give a [ __ ] what you say i'm
going to show you the video from greg
abbott lying to the american public here
but right here at this time stamp you're
going to see
law enforcement come in the building and
what they start doing is a stack
they start stacking in this hallway
and they're trying to find where this
person is actually at at first
so they're stacking through and down the
hallway where he's at
watch as they stack down the hallway
they can hear the gunfire they're in the
school the gunfire is going
and they're starting to stack down the
hallway and they have body armor and
they have weapons
here's where it gets really [ __ ]
really gross
you have some of these officers who run
down the hallway to towards the gunfire
and then yeah doing their job
well
they're supposed to be yeah we're all
right well they're they're good they're
thinking about it yeah yeah then you
have these [ __ ] guys just
nonchalantly walking in like it's a
subway sandwich shop gonna order a
sandwich or some [ __ ]
watch this
[Applause]
there's one two three four five six
seven over half dozen officers in the
school to take this gunman down
now there are i would imagine if they
entered that room with that high-powered
rifle because that's what they're scared
of here folks
they're terrified not of the [ __ ] guy
they're terrified
of the gun they can hear the gun they
know what type of gun this is they know
what it will do to them
it will [ __ ] kill them it will rip
through their body armor that they have
on to protect themselves and most of
these cops are just carrying their
sidearm they don't even have a rifle at
this point
they know what it'll do to him they know
that at least one or two of these
officers that they enter that classroom
at this moment to save those children
that one maybe two of them will lose
their lives
and they should have done that that is
their [ __ ] duty
to lay down their lives to save these
children i don't give [ __ ] what you say
coming home they have children of their
own i don't give a [ __ ]
that is their duty
if you don't want to be a [ __ ] cop
don't be a [ __ ] cop and if you are a
cop maybe you shouldn't vote for
[ __ ] that put weapons of war on
the goddamn street
so let's watch as the gunman starts to
fire
watch what these [ __ ] cowards do
[Music]
there's no one firing no one's firing no
one's entering the classroom it's almost
like they're standing there waiting for
him to come out to shoot himself right
watch he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna fire
his weapon and watch what they do
minutes ticking by
as he's walking from room to room
because we know there's a bathroom in
between these houses
and run down the hallway
they run that all these guys got body
armor and [ __ ] firearms yeah they're
these guys these guys have been
specifically trained
they're in the regulated militia like
this exactly they are the regulated
militia to protect those children right
that's their [ __ ] job
in august of 2020 these guys all got
training
for the unfortunate event of something
like this to happen they were trained
with the proper
uh tactics armor
uh uh
artillery like they were all trained for
how to handle the situation and when
confronted with the very thing that they
said hey when there's an active shooter
this is what you need to take them down
this is what you need to you know uh
deal with the situation they said not
[ __ ] this i'm out i'm out no no no no no
more than one round at more than one
round within a second i'm gone do i
blame another human being for not
wanting to die no it's human nature i i
don't blame but there are children in
that classroom being slaughtered jesus
christ they should have let the parents
go on that school to take out that
gunman
they would have laid their lives on the
line to try to save those kids whether
it was theirs or not now it gets worse
here it gets way worse and what i mean
by that is
these cops
just get more more horrible and more
horrible in this situation here we are
at 11 37 just past 11 37 it's four
minutes
after they have entered the officers
retreat to the hallway and took cover
after shots being fired watch what
happens after this when the timeline
tick-tocks
[Music]
and you notice they now have rifles they
now have shields they now have riot gear
yeah they have they've got what's
necessary to combat what is the current
threat in that classroom not again
they've been trained right
not only do they have bulletproof vet
this is 19 minutes later by the way
they've let him down there in those
classrooms with those children
to slaughter them
while they prepare to not do anything
because that's exactly what they do
here's 31 minutes later
so we're we're 10 minutes past when they
brought the ballistic shields in because
it looks like to me gabe they're waiting
for this guy to walk out so they can
shoot him yeah
because you know the hell with the
children in the classroom they're
worried they're like oh well he's he's
in that classroom he's got to come like
whether he knows that these guys are in
the school or not i don't know but
they're probably yeah they're probably
they're probably waiting for him to go
like okay done with this classroom over
to the next and then get them in between
you know right
and and here's this is what they've been
hiding folks this is what they've been
hiding they waited they're they're
sitting at the end of the hallway with
all the stuff they need to take this
killer out
because greg abbott gave him a gun and
allowed him to get a gun
and here they are standing at the end of
the hallway let's watch
36 minutes later still no rescue attempt
they're still standing around talking as
if they're going to order a subway
sandwich later
on
one guy's on a stone over there
one guy's going through a [ __ ]
checklist how do we do this again guys
what are we supposed to do all right
guys so you got the shields you got you
got the you got the uh are we ready yet
are we ready it's 48 minutes it's been
48 minutes i mean you know it could take
a couple hours to prep to make sure
everyone everyone's good everyone got
their snacks let's let's get a quick nap
in and then we'll come back and yeah yes
but he fires off more rounds and of
course they're alert when he fires off
rounds you know whoa oh there's more
gunfire maybe
oh we're real tough as soon as he comes
out we're gonna be tough i mean as soon
as he walks out after he's done
murdering all the people in those rooms
that we could save that we could have
saved 48 minutes ago
after he's done murdering them he walks
out boy we're gonna be real tough it's
gonna oh man we're gonna we're gonna
pump him full of ammunition here as soon
as he's done doing all the murder
any minute now guys he's gonna come out
any minute now [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
let's watch
[Music]
this is one of the worst parts so
they're moving down the hallway here to
get in a better strategic position
to get him when he comes out of the room
i guess
you see this you see this officer here
in the plaid shirt he's got a helmet
he's got a vest on looks like he was in
street clothes and he you know put on
some armor before he walks in
he really standing over here and he's
you know gabe when you're in a situation
like this you need your hand sanitized i
mean you're like look i gotta i gotta
clean my hands of this children's butt
blood right right right
out of that right right you definitely
would not want this blood of these
children on your answer you gotta
sanitize in the middle of it watch what
this [ __ ] does this is the
attitude of these [ __ ] police
officers
it's 57 minutes by the way yeah what is
he is he reaching for a gun there to go
down and and save those no he's reaching
for hand sanitizer
now watch what he does
the three pump yeah right because you
know sometimes you you can't you know
when you're trying to go both hands
sometimes you know you're thinking like
oh this pump is meant for kids it's a
small portion i got to do i mean there's
children in this school it's not i mean
obviously they're getting murdered down
the hallway yeah yeah so you know you
get it i got to make sure i get an a
fair amount of this
adult you want an adult amount of hands
right you guys are in your hands
holy actual [ __ ] this is the mindset
they're standing around like yeah i mean
this isn't even the worst part yet
[Music]
77 minutes later
77 minutes later is when they breached
the classroom to kill him
seventy
seven minutes
they let that [ __ ] greg abbott gun
that greg abbott mass shooter in that
room with those children and those
teachers to murder them
greg abbott you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
because i'm going to show you how greg
abbott is responsible for this because
he's been trying to cover it since day
one let's watch the rest of this video
you're like i want to get my shot in now
that he's dead
oh yeah now they're tough guys right now
they're tough guys the guy's turning his
hat backwards they really want to go
down there like oh man if i was down
there i would have shot him so good baby
i'm gonna oh man i woulda i would have
got him right between the eyes that's
what i would have done like these guys
afterthought like oh man just [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me unload around in there
and it's like
jesus christ man
like do your [ __ ] job you should have
been down there minutes after right you
came in two and a half minutes after the
[ __ ] first shot was fired right or
rather when he entered the building
and you're just gonna hang out look on
your phone with your punisher american
flag background you're gonna sanitize
your hands to make sure that you don't
have the blood of the children on them
like
incompetent cowardly
cops that's what they are
right
they have no excuse there is no
legitimate excuse if you want to say oh
well you know what they didn't have the
armor they have the shielding they have
the proper
you know uh uh guns to actually fight
off and kill this guy fine boom they
come back in they've got the shields
they've got the helmets they've got the
[ __ ] new guns that they need they've
got everything that they need to
actually protect themselves and and fire
and and bring down this gunman but then
what do they do they hang off they stay
outside and they just watch they just
[ __ ] watch it happen literally
outside the classrooms not down the hall
like these guys but the people who are
up toward the door just watching this
[ __ ] happen
they knew what was going on in those
classrooms they knew he was [ __ ]
murdering them and they did nothing
they did nothing to save those children
you weak cowardly pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you greg abbott i'm gonna go to
this video of greg abbott the statement
that he made let's watch the rest of
this video though
you notice the time here it's 12.50
almost two hours
after he shot the first shots out in the
[ __ ] ditch
that they knew there was a gunman
absolutely [ __ ] devastating we are
over time but i don't give a [ __ ] we're
gonna we're gonna keep going here if
you'll stay with us i'm gonna show you
the footage um
this is what
this is
devastating it should be devastating to
texans it should be devastating to cops
everywhere
um that greg abbott would spew these
[ __ ] lies this is this is just a day
or two after i believe this is his press
conference when he's trying to brief the
public of what happened this
[ __ ] knew this [ __ ] knew
what happened
and listen to the [ __ ] lies that this
[ __ ] people that this [ __ ]
gaslights people with this son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if everyone in texas is
not ready to vote this son of a [ __ ]
out because not only is he willing to
lie to you about guns and gun regulation
he's willing to lie to you about 19
children being [ __ ] torn apart by one
of the weapons that his [ __ ] donors
want him to have in the streets in his
[ __ ] state
this [ __ ] has blood on his hands
[ __ ] greg abbott [ __ ] him let's listen
to this lying piece of [ __ ] garbage
but the reality is as horrible as
what happened
it could have been worse you
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] listen to what he says
about the listen to the lies he tells
the [ __ ] parents of those dead
[ __ ] children who they couldn't even
identify their goddamn bodies
they had to identify him with their
[ __ ] shoes and this [ __ ] is
lying to him listen to this lying piece
of [ __ ] don't look away
the reason it was not worse
is because
law enforcement officials
did what they do
they showed
amazing courage
by running toward gunfire
for the singular purpose of trying to
save lives
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] that
is a [ __ ] lie he [ __ ] knew it he
[ __ ] knows it because he wants to
perpetuate the big good guy bad guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] and convince those [ __ ]
parents that the only way that their
kids weren't safe is because there
weren't more guns there were plenty of
[ __ ] guns in that goddamn school to
save more children plenty of [ __ ]
guns
and they were too much of a [ __ ]
coward to use them that's why it's the
[ __ ] gun
it's the [ __ ] gun the only one that
was willing to fire a weapon is the one
who was murdering children
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] greg abbott
you [ __ ] and then the city
council i have you seen this video of
the city castle oh my god you talk about
bio-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] where they're
[ __ ] trying to gaslight people of
uvalde i mean remember this is the same
you know the same council you've got the
[ __ ] mayor who on the same day that
that you just played the video from from
uh yeah it was better
he comes in he goes do your [ __ ] job
right i mean in so many words and the
mayor was like how dare you how dare you
come in here you son of a [ __ ] it's
like
how dare you
fail this community
fail the parents by lying to their face
about what was actually going on telling
them that the cops ran into fire and
that they were the ones that were going
to save the day the cops that held the
parents back who were willing to run
into the school to save their own
children the very cops who let their own
children out of the school before
actually saving the children of other
parents
this is the community these cops who
were specifically trained in august of
2020 for this exact [ __ ] situation
and what did they do they ran away and
when they came back with the actual
armor and the things that they needed to
do their job
they ran away they waited
you know the reason why they ran away is
the gun it's the [ __ ] gun
it's the gun it's the [ __ ] gun
you [ __ ] idiots stop stop talking
about mental illness those [ __ ]
aren't even they're not doing anything
about guns forget about mental illness
they definitely aren't going to help any
kind of [ __ ] mental illness they're
going to do anything and that only
[ __ ] just disparages anyone with a
mental illness and making them into some
kind of [ __ ] mass shooter which isn't
true at all
it's the [ __ ] gun and greg abbott
the governor of texas
signed a law to make sure
that this 18 year old kid
mental illness not crazy not lunatic not
whatever the case is made sure he could
walk into a gun store buy that gun no
background check on credit with 1700
rounds to make sure he could go
slaughter a bunch of [ __ ] children in
uvalde texas at rob elementary school
and those cops knew the danger of that
gun they [ __ ] knew that's why they
were terrified but let's watch the city
council here and that [ __ ] shitty
mayor
talk about the footage they're so
concerned about the public seeing the
footage which is baffling to me just
absolutely baffling let's watch
well two-thirds of the family are part
of their families are in washington dc
right now and they're gonna have to turn
on the tv and see that tonight not even
with the rest of their family i bet the
parents are begging to see that [ __ ]
dick
[ __ ]
first [ __ ] day you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what a what a what a vile [ __ ]
this guy is and it ain't no it ain't no
wonder he stood up for greg abbott that
day right i mean look these again these
are the parents who were begging
that were detained
from going into the school because the
cops waited outside
these parents were like [ __ ] give me
your bulletproof vest i will go in there
and do it [ __ ] it you won't give me
bulletproof vest i will go in there on
my own
because at least some way some way i
feel like something's being done to
shield these children whether or not
they're still alive
like that's the that's the extent that
these parents are willing to go to lay
down their own life for their children
because it makes sense your children is
helpless in a school where cops are
doing nothing
where someone with with it with a an
ar-15 is shooting up the place
killing one where they aren't able to be
identified unless they're [ __ ]
wearing green shoes
like this is the reality we live in and
that reality was created by greg abbott
and it was bolstered by a community a
council like this and other republicans
like ted cruz or [ __ ]
uh uh
uh anyone else i mean like i'm
[ __ ] man the whole group of these people
created this bolstered it
fueled this fire threw kerosene on it
and then look around and go whoa we
gotta cover this up i don't know how i
don't know one why this fire got so big
and two look at all these firefighters
they did everything they could to put
out the fire
standing around sure but they didn't you
know it's like
listen to the city councilman here who
calls the journalist a chicken [ __ ] just
and they and i'm not sure who shouts
from the crowd but they really give it
back to him this was wrong to do it this
way this video needed to be released but
the family should have got to see it
first
appreciate that thank you sir the mayor
said chicken it was chicken [ __ ] yeah to
release it they're talking about that
the person who released the video is
chicken [ __ ] i get that gabe the
person's scared a chicken [ __ ] right
yeah what a chicken [ __ ] here's the
thing i
and this might be terrible to say but
if i release this video
i may not have
uh suppressed the audio of the children
well i i actually think that
there should be copies of it with the
children that people can listen to and
you should be able to show your [ __ ]
family and your friends exactly what the
[ __ ] these republicans are doing to our
country because we should not you know
like all these other dumb [ __ ] that
trump and these republicans do in terms
of taking over a fascist state like
this is one of those things where you
know
unless we experience it and see it
firsthand or or see the video right
right now it's like yeah this is [ __ ]
terrible to watch this video even
without the the screams of children
because it's like well they didn't do
anything
but
to me
you know much like uh showing someone
who has you know lung cancer or or
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh terrible lungs on the
pack of a cigarettes in europe like i
feel like these are the things where you
have to look at it and you say i do not
want that to ever happen again
and by removing the screams i get it i
understand why they did it but at the
same time
there's an effect that can be done on
people to be like [ __ ] dude no don't we
got to get rid of this this is terrible
to watch i don't even want to watch it
10 seconds into the fire's happening
because i feel terrible because i didn't
do because there wasn't enough done
beforehand and now you know we've got
this happening we are in july
you've got the council abbot and all the
rest of these republicans who are like
there's not a problem look we did as
much as we could on the regulation side
it's as safe as it can be we've got
these red flag laws and we want to care
about mental health awareness and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but when it actually has to have deal
with the actual guns the problem which
is the [ __ ] guns right it's the
[ __ ] guns
they won't do anything
they'll sit by and say yeah no nra we'll
take more money we'll speak at your
events yeah we'll take some lobbying
money here and there but again it's not
the guns
we got to show the video with the audio
and again that might just be me and as
terrible it is to hear that [ __ ] we have
to hear it you know because if we if we
don't look away you can't look away just
wait you can't you cannot look away at
this you have to lean into this
this is what it is this is the reality
this is america and it's not just in
uvalde this could be any elementary
uh
fish eye camera in any elementary
hallway around the country any of them
absolutely any of them because you could
drive to texas get you a gun and go to
an elementary school in whatever state
you want and you go to all kinds of
states to get you a gun to go back to
another state so enough of that [ __ ]
where one state's not regulated the
other one [ __ ]
so let's listen to the a little bit of
let rest of this we are way over time
here video the way you did it that that
part of that video
was not supposed to be in what they're
doing on sunday that was not supposed to
be there they did that for ratings and
they did that for money now that's the
only reason they put that out there
ratings exactly right dumb [ __ ]
ratings is exactly right
every single american every [ __ ] last
person who has their feet on this soil
in this country should have to watch
that [ __ ] video if you're 18 years
old or older you should have to watch
that [ __ ] video as far as i'm
concerned and you don't like it [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
i don't want to end on a crazy note and
i'm super pissed about this but there is
there was one hold on there was one
before we really go there was one video
that that kalyn sent over which is
abbott speaking at an event on may 27th
i think it is
it's a it's a minute long and then we
can you know we can end on a
yeah i want to end on on a laugh here
yeah yeah um
because i just i don't want everyone to
go uh
i want you to stay pissed right yeah i
want you to stay pissed but i also
don't want you to be so pissed you don't
come back tomorrow you got to come back
and watch us tomorrow here's and then i
was given here's the video
um of abbott now uh when is this
this is may 27th
um and then this is the conference two
days later
so this is uh two two days before the
press conference that they just played
everybody has learned
that the information that i was given
turned out in part
to be inaccurate and i'm absolutely
livid about that
law enforcement officials
okay so this is this this is two days
earlier mother in other words
he knows he knows the information that
he has is going to be fire right they've
seen the footage he's light he's lying
here he's lying here watch did what they
do
they showed
amazing courage
by running toward gunfire
for the singular purpose of trying to
save lives
and it is a fact
that because of their quick response
getting on the scene being able to
respond to the gunman and eliminate the
gunman
they were able to save lives
so he knew in his notes he knew in his
notes that they waited for 70 minutes
they waited for other law enforcement
agencies to get there they did not show
bravery they did not run towards the
classroom they didn't they weren't brave
or courageous
they didn't use the things they learned
in the training for this exact event and
the fact that we even have to train for
an event like this is [ __ ] insane
but even after being trained
they said nope not for me which again if
you're hearing gunfire like that and
you're everyday person you'd be like
[ __ ] that i don't want to be anywhere
near it but if you're cops and you're
trained to do it and you have to save
these children
come on
we're going to end on a lighter note but
here's the gun culture
that is what's caused a lot of this
nonsense get a lot of people believe
this nonsense to think it's somehow
their [ __ ] their patriotism with guns
or oh they get these gun boners
but here is uh i don't know who the [ __ ]
this guy is
he apparently he apparently does not
like britain and he does not like delta
dental gabe
um
this appears to be july 4th and we're
going to end on this note i actually
tweeted what in the actual holy hell is
this watch watch this
happy independence day america
freedom is brought to you by a bunch of
guys with guns we're celebrating freedom
from england
and delta dental
this is the sickness that we have here
is i don't know jeff bro in daisy duke
shorts i don't know man cowboy boots on
the back of his truck with a mirror with
an american flag this is something else
right like i mean clearly he's on a
property looks like a barn in the
background so he's probably just
shooting into an open field right
because if this was a neighborhood and
he was like [ __ ] bookshop
like i don't i don't here comes here
comes down the fireworks raining on
innocent children and families who are
trying to enjoy a [ __ ] barbecue i
think this is the shirt of with trump on
a tank have you seen that art and they
put it on shirts and [ __ ] that's what it
looks like here i don't know i've seen
so many things where trump's face put on
[ __ ] you know but what's wrong with
little [ __ ] too here's my real question
well i got two i got two questions
number one
he definitely cut these jeans up right
oh yeah right he did that i'm surprised
that we're not seeing a couple balls
dangling out the corner well if you if
you zoom in you might you might get you
a nine fool
so that's my first question is did he is
he the one who cut the jeans up yeah
look at that pocket that pocket like the
whole pocket is beneath the shorts i
know man the daisy dukes
uh you know i don't i don't know what
this guy's trying to tell us with the
daisy dukes but my second question is
this
why why delta dental i don't under why
what the [ __ ] did delta dental do to
this guy
he was like [ __ ] they [ __ ] up my molar
insurance like i don't know i have no
idea i think i've for the my most of my
life i've had
some like delta dental at least for my
insurance that i've paid for through
companies like i don't know any other
dentist insurance company i'm sure there
are others but
the only one that i know of right well
and he's just really upset about his
freedom against britain
and against
delta dental let's watch one more time
and then is he a dentist he might be a
dentist i don't know maybe happy
independence day america
freedom is brought to you by a bunch of
guys with guns we're celebrating freedom
from england
and delta dental
i like also i like also he goes we're
celebrating freedom from
uh uh uh
you know like he's like like he takes it
off he's like right right which one is
it which one am i going to say here am i
going to say the states of america or is
it britain us or is it delta that like
he was trying to figure out like all
right where do i who's the enemy who's
who who am i going to lead in with right
am i going to go in with britain or i'm
going to go with delta dental
we held the audience for 20 extra
minutes i think this proves we could do
three hours a day gabe i'm just saying
i'm not saying we're going to
but if we had to we could we definitely
we definitely and i missed a lot of
stuff i didn't even play the josh hawley
video so everyone go watch josh
[ __ ]
for being a goddamn homophobe and a
transphobe just gets his ass late i'm
i'm being transphobic it's like yeah you
are you are being transphobic you're
[ __ ] seditionist before i start my
statement i just want to say you're a
pile of [ __ ] [ __ ] i would have been
much i would have been much more
forceful with it yeah yeah she did it i
just want everyone i just want to know
like so everyone knows that josh hawley
is a piece of [ __ ] now you're also being
transphobic but first and foremost i
feel sorry for your wife you're a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] so well in there well in
there stay pissed stay pissed engage in
your democracy because you got you got
[ __ ] weirdos like this that are out
there trying to bang it up and you got
[ __ ] transphobes like josh hawley
trying to actually do policy you have to
engage in your democracy it's so
important
and go watch that video of you aldi
show your family show your friends they
need to know what happened in those
hallways and they need to know that
those are the hallways of their schools
that is america and we need to change it
we we the people can change it don't
forget to come back tomorrow at the same
time noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific youtube twitter twitch
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page until then surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking